still working on that afternoon almond
i've been sucking on it so long it's
smooth it's like sea glass you do you
i'll get that for you ames
[Music]
oops butterfeet sorry about that sorry
you bumbling son of a [ __ ] you just
ruined my life i hope you get hit by a
truck and a dog takes a dump on your
face nothing to see here just a little
hypoglycemic rage move along i'm so
sorry hitchcock that's not me i'm never
like that that's okay it's my fault i
shouldn't bump your cashew
cashew it was an almond you idiot i hope
you drown in a tub i hope you have
annual semester aneurysm after aneurysm
don't make me hit you again
um i'm building this dollhouse for my
girls it's their birthday tomorrow i
told my wife i'd get it done i had the
same exact one when i was a kid
mom charles is hogging my dollhouse
grandma bought it for the both of us you
want some help big man no
i can do
this it's just driving me a little crazy
where do i fix the prince's tower boyle
where do i fix it inside of the truck
now boyle
let it brother breathe
better brother breathe
sarge do we have any old t-shirts in
here
detectives ah captain did you come down
here to take a look at the two best
detectives you've ever worked with in
action the two best detectives i've ever
worked with are montez and dillman now
you've never mentioned that before they
were excellent i'm here because major
crimes wants this case i was hoping to
tell them you have some leads i
overheard you mention a bill beau
baggins should we bring him in well as
much as i would love to meet him he is
not a suspect okay so who is at this
time no one but
we are currently investigating no leads
so you have nothing no nothing jake made
a new best friend the vic's mom he
promised her he'd solve the case that's
a rookie mistake okay fine so maybe i'm
not montana and dilbert montez and
dillman and they would have remembered
your name after one mention because
we're memorable and they're not turned
it around no right look captain rosa and
i are gonna solve this case the answer
is in this room we just have to focus
and let the room speak to us isn't that
right room when you talk to the room i
lose even more confidence in you why oh
wait i see it all right can you please
just buy some more time anyway sir i
feel like we've earned this
fine we're fast you got it
okay let's look at the scene like we're
seeing it for the first time with fresh
eyes vic was face down cast off splatter
suggests upward knife slices no signs of
forced entry laptop wallet keys were all
there doesn't canota robbery wait a
minute have we said this already are we
just having the exact same conversation
yep cool moving on windows and doors
locked from the inside nobody in or out
think think think oh the upstairs
neighbor and his best friend drill
through the ceiling murder atoms bleed
all over the apartment then climb back
up and seal the hole behind them
negative we would have found
construction debris and microscopic
paint fibers the only thing that needs
patching
is that therium
okay new idea we're gonna get inside the
mind of the killer we eat the veggie
wraps
here we go
oh this [ __ ] bastard oh man this is one
twisted mother oh the pizza raw this guy
is demented rosa okay all we have to do
is figure out what kind of person can
walk by cameras without being seen
someone camouflaged as a wall unlikely
harry potter and his invisibility club
not a real person papa dude doesn't
exist what about a looper situation not
a looper it could totally be a looper
situation a looper situation my least
favorite hair oh my god rosa come here
look at the blood spatter do you see
what i see uh blood in the exact shape
of dwayne the rock johnson peck peck
dealt dealt big samoan tattoo rosa i
think there's a major connection the
number three is everywhere three people
three types of blood and guess what the
tax was on the veggie wraps
three dollars
and 19 cents but if you ignore the 19
then it's three okay you've lost your
mind what who told you that was it room
no it's the fact that you think the room
has a voice and also you're working in
your boxers what to beat the heat rosa
to beat the heat we can't turn on the ac
that's not crazy it's just smart jake i
gave the case to major crimes what you
can't do that i promised luanne yeah and
now you can't let it go the scene's
yours guys
i'm sorry jake it's over okay rosa fine
i'll leave come on room
you left your pants i don't care
you need to go to a hospital right now i
don't want a birth happening around me
it's way too gross i'm nowhere near
giving birth i haven't even lost my
mucus plug amy you need to get out of
here i'm sorry my baby grosses you out
rosa i'm excited to meet your baby when
it's clean and wearing clothes and not
blasting out of you like some half cuban
jimmy neutron i'm just at the start of
my labor your baby's coming it's still
not active labor don't worry i'm not
gonna have the baby here and get
placenta all over your desk or whatever
it is that you're afraid of wait is
placenta something that can get all over
actually technically you know what don't
answer that i don't want to know
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one are you trying to
monty hall me
it's unbelievable i don't need monty
hall ruining my place of work when monty
hall has already ruined my home life
come on sir the math thing isn't the
problem night shift's keeping you and
kevin apart you two just need a bone
what did you say don't say it again i
said you two need a bone
how
dare you detective diaz i am your
superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business bone
don't ever speak to me like that again
why did you do that dude just pen up now
he knows problem solved
[Music]
just eating butter like a popsicle huh
boyle yeah i know i'm spoiling myself
but i'm depressed or have you forgotten
that jake my best friend is in prison
wait jake's in prison yeah he and rosa
were praying for a bunch of bank
robberies by lieutenant hawkins oh right
and where's gina on maternity leave we
were all at her baby shower last week
okay and why am i bleeding i don't know
hitchcock oh so you don't have all the
answers
i'm bleeding because my piece of crap
son-in-law bit me look we all miss jake
and rosa which is why we have to keep
working the case there has to be some
way to exonerate him i've been looking
but i can't find anything and i don't
know what to do i can't find anything
and i don't know what to do title of
your sex tape what is happening right
now they caught hawkins trying to flee
the country she confessed to everything
and they let me out oh my god jake is it
really you are you really here you know
it baby but first
i gotta hug my best friend
welcome back peralta i just heard from
the mayor to apologize for what happened
to you they're sending you to disney
world you and one male guest as long as
i don't have to go on any of the scary
rides i just go for the shows
boil boil boil boil boil boil boil
were you dreaming about jake again why
didn't you wake me up i told you never
to wake me up all right thanks
okay here's what esther remembers about
the night that she was around she was
either at our restaurant or the movies
or doing something else and she was
either alone or with people the only
thing she was absolutely sure of is that
i seemed like a very nice boy which is
not relevant to the case but did make me
feel very good this is stupid
it was 20 years ago no one remembers
anything
i'm beginning to think maybe we should
climb out on that ledge and see how the
perp got in i was gonna say give up what
right after i came up with that
incredible ledge thing terry we're ten
stories up you can handle that sarge i'm
not scared of heights okay i'm scared of
bees i'm scared of snakes and i'm scared
that the knicks might never be good
again but i am not scared of heights
we're gonna die we're gonna die we're
gonna die we're gonna die we're gonna
die we're gonna die we're gonna die
i would appreciate it if you didn't tell
anyone
you